I don't think my view is arbitrary I
just don't think transgenderism is true
and age we're talking about well but
this gets to age because for all of
human history pretty much no one has
thought that transgender the transgender
idea really is true and you don't seem
to think that it really is true it's
interesting well I think I view it
different I have a different definition
but here's the inconsistency that I I
find in your point you say that when you
turn 18 you ought to be able to chop
yourself up and put on a dress and go
into a women's bathroom and putting
aside the public issues that come from
that I just wonder how it is the case
that transgenderism is false for the
first 18 years and then suddenly becomes
true when one turns 18. and if that is
not what's really happening if it is
false and your trepidation in exposing
children to this is because it obviously
is false if it's false and harmful for
children why is it beneficial and true
for adults